retour en france avec cet hommage aux
morts de la rue à paris comme chaque
année le collectif les morts de la rue
au nord les personnes sans abri décédées
en france l'année précédente soit 535
personnes en 2020 leurs noms a été
dévoilée ce matin lors d'une cérémonie
aux buttes-chaumont un hommage pour
interpeller le gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron dont les promesses de 2017 n'ont
pas été tenues pour en parler on
retrouve sur place david khalifa david
bonjour vous êtes aux buttes-chaumont
comment se déroule cet hommage aux
personnes sans abri des cv en 2020 une
cérémonie un peu particulière doha en
raison de la crise sanitaire vous
l'aurez compris pas de rassemblement
mais des points de rendez-vous qui sont
disposés un peu partout dans le parc des
buttes chaumont dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris pour
sensibiliser tous les visiteurs à des
roe sont également distribués à l'entrée
du parc et sur les grilles du parc des
grands panneaux sont affichés avec le
nom et la date le lieu et le lieu de la
mort de ses cinq cent trente cinq
personnes mortes en 2020 à noter aussi
ces petits pots de fleurs qui sont
disposés tout autour du parc tout autour
de ce lac ou des petites affiches
également sont inscrits sont collés sur
ses pots de fleurs où on ne peut
apercevoir le nom l'âge et à la date à
deux mordus de ces personnes de ces 535
personnes mortes en 2020 est dans la rue
à savoir que ce chiffre 535 et non
exhaustif et qui peut être multiplié par
6 1 selon le collectif à l'initiative de
cette mobilisation
je trouve actuellement justement avec la
présidente a dû collectif
bérengère à ghisoni merci est d'être
avec nous alors malgré le contexte
sanitaire c'était important pour vous de
de faire cette cérémonie d'hommage qui a
lieu chaque année puisque la dernière on
se souvient à cause du confinement il
n'a pas eu lieu voilà c'était important
l'année dernière on a été obligé
d'annuler le
le chômage en présentiel à la dernière
minute à cause du confinement et à
l'idée de l'annuler à nouveau une
deuxième année d'affilée
ça nous était vraiment difficile donc on
a fait en sorte de le faire de façon
espacée sans rassemblement mais c'était
important qu'on puisse le faire
au coeur de la ville alors l'objectif
c'est de sensibiliser tous les toutous
les gens tous les citoyens français
vis-à-vis de sa soeur 30 35 personnes
mortes dans la rue en 2020 nécessitent
aussi d'interpeller le gouvernement on
se souvient qu emmanuel macron en 2017
avait promis qu'il n'y aurait plus un
sdf dans la rue au début de son
quinquennat promesses non tenues
malheureusement c'est voilà c'est qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire de plus en tout cas
nous on est là pour rappeler ça fait
depuis des années des décennies
victor hugo à l'a fait bien avant nous
l'abbé pierre et donc on est là depuis
longtemps pour dénoncer ces morts
prématurées 49 ans de vie en moyenne
dénoncer ses conditions de survie c'est
inacceptable comment ça se fait que des
personnes dans nos rues en 2020 2021
aussi nombreuse des centaines on le
disait tout à l'heure on arriverait
vraisemblablement à trois fois 6 fois
plus à plus de 3000 personnes qui
décèdent dans la france des conséquences
d'une vie à la rue
donc effectivement on est là aujourd'hui
et pour honorer ces personnes le faire
savoir
et puis rappeler à tout le monde aux
citoyens aux gouvernements aux
institutions à tous les partenaires que
mourir à la rue ce n'est pas une
fatalité
autre chose et est mise en place à part
votre collectif et la possibilité de
faire des vidéos pour ces gens qui ont
côtoyé ces sdf qui est qu'ils sont
mortes dans la rue en 2020 et de
partager en fait c'est sa petite fessée
vidéo 535 au total sont attendues et à
ce moment là vous pouvez les partager
sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà on a parallèlement construit un
homme
j'ai numérique qu'on a mis en ligne ce
matin avec cet appel à à 535 vidéo en
hommage à 1 535 personnes dont nous
avons eu connaissance de leur décès on
en a recueilli déjà 120 et on va
continuer d'alimenter autant qu'il le
faudra ce site
donc n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
vidéos hommage que ce soit un message de
tendresse un message en tentant une
personne que vous auriez connu un
message coup de gueule votre réaction
on attend vos vidéos merci beaucoup mais
en juin dernier la présidente je rappel
à dieu collectif morts les morts de la
rue alors ce rassemblement tout parce
qu'il n'est pas vraiment rassemblement
comme je vous le disais un soutien ici
aux buttes chaumont avec des points de
rendez-vous pour sensibiliser toutes ces
personnes elles pour rappel à
sensibiliser les personnes mais
également le gouvernement puisque depuis
à 2017
c'est un minimum 500 personnes qui
meurent dans la rue chaque année à noter
également ce chiffre 300 milles sdf en
2020 selon le décompte officiel de
l'abbé pierre des décomptes encore une
fois qui ceux qui se font à
difficilement pour ses organes de
comptage puisque les retours sont
compliqués à travers la france mais
voilà des chiffres qui a qui explique
vraiment que les manuels mâcon n'a pas
tenu ses promesses concernant les sdf et
les personnes qui sont mortes dans la
rue chaque année merci beaucoup d'avis
de khalifa pour toutes ces précisions en
direct à des buttes chaumont à paris